let's have a look at this trigonometric
identity proof
together now
when you have a look at this part of
what is just messy is all these
fractions flying around
sarang asked a very common question that
students actually do for this maybe if
you're having a look at
if you have a look at someone else's
working they did this that first
fraction one plus cos theta
all divided by sine theta um oh sorry
wait
let me ask that question again what are
you talking about this one or this one
the first one okay so certain question
was can i break apart
that fraction into wrong color one on
sine theta plus
cos theta on sine theta i want to know
what your opinion is on can he do that
can he do that i'm getting some nods
some kind of what's the question yeah
i'm getting notes
okay i'm getting nods accurately because
yes you can take the first fraction on
the left here
and turn it into this however
i'm going to suggest not a helpful way
to go and i'll tell you how i knew
without even having done this question
yet
this is a proof where
hello who are you looking for um
sorry just let me grab that um
shiny and did yeah
um hsi you start from now apparently
thank you and you're looking for and
john
you also you also won the lottery sorry
oh one more
[Music]
yeah i'm on the way okay so what are we
trying to do here we're trying to
turn one of these sides into the other
left hand side to right
or right hand side to left there's a
fairly obvious one that you can start
with which side makes more sense to
start with
the the left the harder one because it's
messy our brains are much better at
simplifying messy things
than messing simple things you're like
what am i supposed to do with this okay
so we're going to start with our left
hand side and i'm going to move from
there
to there but to serene's original
question suggestion
does it help me to break this one
fraction
into two and i would argue probably not
because i'm trying to get all of this
mess into one term
and this actually says to separate them
out into
more different terms does that make
sense serene
because that was your suggestion do you
see why i'm not going to do that yeah
okay so here's what i'm going to do
left-hand side okay i'm going to start
working with this thing now there are
two fractions
so my immediate first thing is when
you've got two fractions that have as
you can see
different denominators what's your
instinct if you're going to combine
these
i'm going to i'm going to multiply the
two denominators together to get a
common denominator do you agree with
that
a common denominator is something i'm
really after so let's go ahead and do
that
so i get 1 plus cos theta
on sine theta and i'll multiply the top
and the bottom by the other denominator
this guy over here okay now being that
this numerator happens to coincidentally
be
the same as the other denominator i just
get it squared
and then you get 1 plus cos theta also
on the denominator so far so good
i'm on my way we'll do the same thing
with the other guy and then i notice
there's this weird symmetry to this
right
you're like oh this denominator is the
same as this numerator
so i'm going to go that's going to be
sine
squared theta because i multiply it by
sine and then over here
i get the same denominator because after
all that was the point that's what i was
trying to head towards
so far so good great so the whole point
of having a common denominator is i can
now combine these two fractions into one
so that gives me one plus cos theta all
squared
plus sine squared all over
this rather long and messy denominator
okay let me pause question is that where
you're going to turn sine squared theta
into
cos minus okay so
so i am definitely going to be if you
think back to yesterday's lesson
i am definitely going to be using what
we call the pythagorean identity do you
remember that guy
right cos squared plus sine squared
equals 1.
okay i'm going to use that but i'm not
i'm not ready yet
okay this thing here needs to be
expanded out with a little bit of care
okay so let's let's do this
this here one plus cos theta or squared
can you help me out this is a binomial
being expanded what am i gonna get when
i expand
one one good start plus
2 cos theta i heard plus
cos squared and then there's that sine
squared that's still hanging out on the
end there so far so good
so that is all divided through by the
same denominator nothing's happened to
that denominator
okay now i'm just going to pause here
for a moment before i go any further
i think you guys can see at this point
you're like oh that thing i recognize
right and then also i go back to what
i'm trying to
go toward this is a little bit like you
know i've got my destination in mind
so i'm like driving toward there and
thinking how can i get closer
to cosec theta this is a
what kind of identity is that cosec is
its own identity right what is it
it's it's a trig identity of what one
over one over sine
right you've got that s there which
tells you it's one over sine
so in other words like my second last
line will be
1 over sorry 2 over sine theta do you
agree
and look look see that sine theta that's
down there you're like oh that's good
this other thing that's not supposed to
be there so eventually i hope it will
cancel
will it cancel yeah it will because
that's a one so one plus one gives you
two right and then
wait wait one this is one plus
this is one do you see that yeah that's
an identity we know
and then you can see i can factorize out
one plus cos theta on the top
or i can factor out two is an easy way
to say it factor out two
leaves you with maybe i'll write it for
you just so you can see it one plus cos
theta
in the brackets that leaves you with a
sine theta on the bottom
and a one plus cos theta which is about
to cancel you see that
so there goes the cancel cancel and then
literally my next line
is that and i'm done does that make
sense you see where i got there
now this was a three mark question i'll
tell you right now
i'll tell you right now where the three
marks were you might be able to guess
have a think this is definitely going to
be marked here right
all right we know to use that identity
what else do you think of like the big
things that we did
the big changes that we had to make
yeah i'm gonna call these two lines
together right
um we were putting them on a common
denominator and then uh we also started
to expand that one plus cos theta okay
so there's a mark and then here's your
um here's your final stretch
right you have to do that factorization
which then leaves you with just the sine
theta
and then it becomes a reciprocal you
don't get anything for that last line
because
we gave you that in the question okay
any questions on that
now what did i do that you didn't do
part of what i just did is easy for you
to learn part of it's hard okay i'll
tell you the hard part first
the hard part is i look at
i look at this line and i instantly know
eventually i'm going to get to this
because i'm like oh there's going to be
some multiplication there's going to be
some cross
multiplying here cos squares sine
squared so eventually i kind of i have
this intuition that i'm heading in that
general erection
but even if you did not know that that's
where you were going
you all know you've got to take two
fractions combine them into one you guys
can handle that
um this is on the reference sheet you
don't need to remember it's there
right this guy here you did need to know
but hopefully by
the time you get to this point it jogs
your memory okay